monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre depuis dimanche dernier la
France est sous le choc
Lola une jeune fille de 12 ans
a été sauvagement agressé et les mortes
agressée par une ressortissante
algérienne qui n'aurait pas dû être sur
le sol français
depuis dimanche des voies s'élèvent pour
que d'autres devoirs se taisent pour
imposer le silence
pour bâillonner le débat
mais l'essence même de la démocratie mes
chers collègues précisément cette
questionnement c'est le débat le meurtre
de Lola me rappelle un autre meurtre qui
m'avait touché personnellement
le meurtrier à l'époque était depuis
plus de 10 ans en situation irrégulière
il était sur le sol de France
il avait été frappé par trois occultés F
il n'était pas expulsé il a incendié la
cathédrale de Nantes il n'était pas en
prison
il avait une santé précaire mentale il
n'était pas un hôpital psychiatrique et
vous voudriez madame le Premier ministre
que nous nous taisions ce sont les
Français qui réclament des comptes et il
faut l'admettre le désordre migratoire
peut tuer si cet algérienne n'avait pas
été sur le sol français Lola aurait été
encore en vie j'ai une double question à
vous poser la première reconnaissez-vous
des défaillances de l'État
une part de responsabilité
la seconde que dites-vous aux Français
pour que ces tragédies et ces drames ne
se reproduisent plus